porque con ese segundo imitaba al día
vamos a hablar del mundo laboral cómo ha
cambiado y evolucionado tras la pandemia
de kobe 19 muchos empleos se han
transformado debido a la competencia
actual hasta las reglas de la búsqueda
de nuestros empleos la destrucción de
una parte importante de la fuerza
laboral también es una consecuencia
derivada de la crisis sanitaria la
realidad es que esta pandemia está
condicionando los parámetros de los
procesos de reclutamiento y también
selecciona así como la forma en que
nosotros estamos buscando nuestros
empleos pero cuáles son los retos en el
ámbito laboral postpandemia pues lo
vamos a analizar con gerard radicales
especialista en políticas de empleo en
la oficina de la organización
internacional del trabajo para el cono
sur de américa latina gracias a gerard
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de francia 24 hablemos entonces
de cómo ha cambiado que tanto se ha
transformado y evolucionado digamos el
empleo en todas sus formas desde cómo
emplea una persona que como nosotros
también lo buscamos por supuesto hablar
del teletrabajo que llegó para quedarse
sin duda y también para reemplazar en
muchos casos la oficina
buenos dias raúl y muchas gracias por la
invitación bueno definitivamente
sentimos como una suerte de
normalización en el mercado laboral pero
es una normalización tanto extraña no
por un lado está incompleta porque
todavía
hay muchas como gentes sobre todo que no
han podido volver al mercado laboral y
vemos también tiene de repente por un
brote de cúbito de otras enfermedades
respiratorias
anticipan las vacaciones se mandan a
volver a la educación
remota y muchas veces son las mujeres
precisamente que se tienen que quedar en
casa para cuidar a sus hijos entonces
hay un impacto también en el mercado
laboral vemos también que en algunos
sectores donde se han achicado mucho
durante la pandemia por ejemplo en
líneas áreas y ahora se ven con escasez
de mejora en la europa en este momento
en el verano europeo hay un caos en la
aviación
y también las cadenas de suministro como
que se niegan a normalizarse que todavía
el transporte está complicado en cierto
cargo que hay insumos que no llegan
entonces es una
normalidad relativa y si vamos al tema
que usted mencionaba del teletrabajo
efectivamente
llegó para quedarse
en chile por ejemplo hay un estudio
reciente de empresas importantes y el
70% de esas empresas actualmente sigue
haciendo
jornada sibilidad es decir que bueno por
ejemplo tienen dos días remotos y 3 días
presenciales y solamente 15 estaba en
presencial el full y 15%
en teletrabajo full entonces a esa moda
y parece ser la que más impone y
obviamente hay un montón de desafíos
sobre los que podemos hablar que
conlleva esa modalidad eso le quiero
preguntar llegar los desafíos para los
empleados para los empleadores cuáles
son los retos que tenemos en la
actualidad y pues no sé si usar también
esa palabra de una normalidad porque
pues es evidente que todo todo ha
cambiado y todo cambio ya después de
esta pandemia de kobe 19 entonces
digamos cuál sería esa nueva normalidad
a la que vamos a estar enfrentados la
que vamos a vivir mejor dicho la que
estamos viviendo ahora
y bueno hay que decir que la hoja del
del trabajo empezó de antes y por lo
tanto también algunos países habían
empezado a regular esta modalidad pero
en pandemia obviamente fue una modalidad
de emergencia y los países que no lo
tenían
regulado
hubo mucha mucha regulación hasta
grávida y pero no es lo mismo
el teletrabajo como una modalidad
excepcional de emergencia y por tanto
obligatoria porque no hay posibilidad de
trabajar en la oficina
con una modalidad permanente y regular
que debería ser voluntaria entonces es
la regulación
[Música]
hay que adaptarla actualizarla y
encontrar la model ya permanente donde
estén resguardados los derechos tanto de
empleadores como de trabajadores y para
mencionar algunos ejemplos impactantes
es bueno el evitar jornadas excesivas de
respetar la separación entre la vida
privada y la vida de trabajo el
solucionar de quien asume los costos por
el espacio en las casas por
por la conectividad internet por un
lugar trabajo económico en casa que hay
toda una serie de temas que hay que
regular y también el diálogo social que
cuando las personas están juntas es más
fácil juntarse para por ejemplo una
reunión sindical y es más complejo
cuando todos están en casa o parte en
casa de pata en la oficina muy
rápidamente llegar también la la onu
digamos recomendó hizo algunas
recomendaciones para esta nueva era
laboral postpandemia dijo que tenemos
que tener una
inclusiva ecológica y sostenible se
entrada pues en los trabajadores en el
ser humano realmente esto es posible y
más allá si es posible sí sí ya se está
empezando a poner en marcha un plan
inclusivo ecológico y sostenible
con efectivamente esas dos dimensiones
son muy importantes también desde la oit
el lema de una recuperación que no deja
a nadie atrás porque
en este panorama que estábamos viendo
tendrá el teletrabajo también es está
llegando cada vez más hacia el trabajo
administrativo de gestión
mientras que los obreros por ejemplo los
trabajos más manuales se tienen que
seguir desarrollando en lugares físicos
en la fábrica en oficinas sí y
claramente el trabajo a domicilio brinda
algunas algunas algunas ventajas que a
las que no tienen acceso a todos los
trabajadores y por otro lado como decía
la transición hacia una economía más
sostenible terminado medioambiental es
muy importante y es una transición que
hay que gestionar de forma de que no
crea de una pérdida de empleos porque
algunos procesos que uno pueda analizar
van a crear empleo y otras que van a
mirar qué pérdida del empleo entonces
hay que ver la secuencia de tal forma
que haya siempre un equilibrio
equilibrio para que no haya de golpe una
disminución de empleo y los controles en
todo estos procesos hay
adaptaciones hay ganadores y perdedores
hay gente que va a perder su trabajo y
que hay que insertar los entonces está
el desafío de la capacitación de la
formación profesional para volver a
ponerlo en condiciones a que puedan
encontrar trabajo la intermediación
laboral en ese punto una serie de tareas
para la política de empleo de hecho
llegar un buen tema ley queda la
invitación abierta para hablar de esa
transición de ese empleado algo más
sostenible más ecológico digamos más
verde porque ese tema nos llevaría
también solamente una entrevista para
hablar de eso llegar gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros en directo
américa gracias a usted